(audience applauds)
- Welcome back!
Before we go, we like to
play a quick round of!
- Drewth or Dare!
(audience applauds)
All right.
- Do we have Calmey LaGrandeo?
Hello!
- Hi! Hi there!
- [Ross] Okay, best
suit of the day, hello!
- Thank you! Thank you!
- All right, so what's it gonna be today?
Is it gonna be a Drewth or a dare?
- Dare!
- [Ross] Okay.
(audience applauds)
- I like how you revved up for it.
(Ross makes revving sound)
(audience laughs)
(indistinct)
What's coming down the pike.
- You ready?
- [Drew] I think so.
Yes, always.
- Yes.
- Drew.
- [Drew] Okay.
- I dare you to try to crack an egg
without getting any shell in the bowl.
But there's a twist.
Ross will be behind you.
And you have to use his
hands instead of your own.
And Ross will be blindfolded.
- [Drew] I already like this, yeah.
- Drew, your hands will
be behind your back
and you have to guide
Ross the entire time.
- [Ross] Okay.
- So it's your hands, my eyes.
- Yes, and we'll work as a unit.
(audience applauds)
- [Calmey] You ready? Okay, good luck!
- Is it in the kitchen?
- Are we going in the kitchen?
- Okay.
All right, Drew.
- [Calmey] Remember, no shell.
No shell in the bowl.
- Okay.
- Wait, is this the blindfold?
- [Calmey] Wear your aprons!
- Okay, I'm gonna put on this,
I don't want you to get dirty.
So I'm gonna put a little...
- [Drew] Thank you.
- That's cute, you ready?
All right, cute, cute, cute.
- You strap me in, I'll strap you in.
- [Ross] Oh!
- [Audience] Ooh.
- Okay, blind fold me.
- Okay, here.
- And even though I'm in the heels,
thank you, Rossy, for coming up.
- You can do this.
- [Ross] I'm gonna get behind you.
Guide me.
- Okay, forward.
- Okay.
- Okay, and now go down and get the eggs.
- Oh, that's an egg.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Now wait, okay.
Okay, keep your hands straight.
- [Ross] Well, girl, come
on, I can't do straight.
(audience laughs)
- Your hand!
Keep your hands straight.
- Okay.
- Okay, now one, two, three.
(audience laughs)
- [Ross] I think that worked.
- [Drew] All right, pick the bowl up.
- Okay.
- No. Yeah, get that egg out.
(audience laughs)
Here we go, okay.
- Okay, now...
- Count me in.
- Okay, you...
Uh-huh, uh-huh.
- Okay?
- Right there, right there.
- Yeah, uh-huh.
(audience laughs)
- I'm gonna do a little softer.
Okay, ready?
Three, two, delicate.
Oh, okay.
- [Drew] Oh no, this is not gonna go well.
- [Ross] It's gonna go great.
- [Drew] All right.
(audience cheers)
- Okay.
Any shell in the bowl?
- Calmey, I'm really sad to tell you
there's a tiny bit of shell.
But I am very proud of Rossy,
because not only did the
last egg he get in the bowl,
he didn't break the yolk.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
How did I do?
- Look.
- [Ross] Oh God.
- [Drew] You didn't break it.
- How about that! Hey!
(audience applauds)
- [Calmey] Whoo, good job!
- That wasn't bad.
- Well, thank you, Calmey.
- I have to say, Drew,
that one really cracked me up.
(upbeat music)